she lied with the cast of river now part
two from comic-con I'm weird Galera how
you doing guys I got to keep the energy
up I know you're exhausted
give me some of mine I feel like it you
must be so thank you I've just got a
compliment all the ladies right now you
look incredible your comic-con fashion
is crushing it we're keeping it real
though but you not we're done using a
coal you want a special shot yes you
guys we gotta talk about season three
you guys are up back in Vancouver back
on the set of pops with its new little
speakeasy have you discovered that set
just yeah I know it's being built yeah
we do we lost
Archie's garage for know that don't move
to a different sounds games it did yeah
so we still have our T's garage where he
will be doing all of his push-ups and
chin-ups
yeah so right good with that on let's
talk about your reaction to the season
three premiere script what was your
initial thought when you finished that
script jacket dies again I really
appreciated the new mystery that we have
we kind of go start off really strong
and with a brand new mystery a bunch of
new storylines enclosure of old
storylines I feel like but the mystery
is really the mystery is really cool
it's different from what we've done in
the first juicy is very cool and also I
feel like we started off strong as like
a unit and it's like we're all kind of
sorting together which is cool
okay in addition to a brand new mystery
we have some brand new serpents in the
groove Madeline and of course Lily we
haven't officially seen Betty get her
jacket just yet but is it safe to assume
that she will accept that serpent Queen
crown it's safe to assume
yeah she wears it with pride I think
little snake her mother yeah but how
does it feel for you guys and we will be
talking about cabbage so just one more
time how does it feel for you guys to
have the Serpent's expand and to be able
to share so many more scenes together
because I feel like we haven't even
really got many like Cheryl and Jughead
scenes a long time yeah that's great the
scenes take way longer now that she's a
part of the search I'm sorry are you
serious Vanessa fans fell in love with
you is Tony topaz I see you're paying
homage to her today with your purple
this is way more girly than than Tony
would yeah yeah the purple I the party
line yes the big purple I in the middle
of your head um you know my third act
vanna's really fell in love with Cheryl
and Tony's relationship Shoni as we've
officially named it now that they're
both surfing around now that these
ladies are officially serpens together
can we get some more scenes together
that will stay in the episodes we really
hope say well we'll try our best I
really enjoyed the fact that Kevin and
moose had a little lip lock after so
much awaited flirtations uh what is
coming up for him this year do you think
that romance will continue yes yes Kevin
and moose
and bopping around town all summer
they're there in that right they're
about to start dating I think and it's
it's fun it's interesting Kevin or moose
is a little closeted so that's kind of
hard challenge kick Jenner challenge
incompletes a little thing they're gonna
do together which is very exciting
little Club you're gonna be a little bit
of a time jump it sounds like good
three-month three months okay the end of
summer so skipping summer would you ever
like to see the river aliens in
summertime like slip I'll be back to
wearing sweaters before you know it yeah
there's some really fun summer outfits
truly yeah no I love wait I love your
sweaters though you did just tweet a
really cute collar cardigan with a bunch
of little bells on yes like there's a
lot of cool Betty summer fashion well
speaking of bugs let's talk about bug
head what is ahead for them this year at
Lillian Cole what would you like to see
from them as a couple because there was
a lot of ups and downs last year maybe a
little bit more just consistency mm-hmm
you know happiness no actually it's
looking like it's gonna be pretty good
for bug head this season so far pretty
constant pretty nice two episodes in
that Betty and jacket are kind of back
to being the investigative sleuths that
they were in season one so it's kind of
it's like they're back to their old
selves again which is kind of fun to see
solving mysteries sleuthing around I
would love to get some more answers of
FP and Alice's past we got a little bit
we we learned about their son that they
had together then we learned of his
apparent passing is that something that
we should take as gospel or is there
some wiggle room as to well you know
Riverdale is tricky that way and I think
somebody is
and then they just come right back one
thing and then they just really lose a
bit there's enough time there's a lot of
history between us well and but your
on-screen dynamic together is so
fantastic i FB we had d period talked
about it I have to carry a lot that's
okay appreciated what questions do you
guys have about FP analysis past or you
hoping we'll get answered because they
have a long history together what
happened when it went wrong
yeah what did you what did you do I
don't know why Alice left the serpents
and what that whole wouldn't ship a guy
it was a scene it was there was a scene
between Betty and Alice that did talk
about that when she made a decision to
go with Hal instead FP and it was just
to sort of I really know how it was
really about she might pick the more
future
[Music]
yes jellybean update jellybeans for me
yeah jellybeans are coming in this
season really have you been suggesting
anybody that you would like to play your
little sister
Dylan was it was a scheduling conflict
no I mean honestly whoever is going to
be best for the rule is gonna be best
for our cast has been so well cast and I
I have full faith that David Rock The
Rock reports kind of knock it out of the
park with clothes my mother and Jamie I
just want to see Cheryl continue to rule
the school and now that she's got the
assortments backing her up can we expect
her to be even more fierce this year
Cheryl comes in with fire in her belly
and excitement about feeling like she's
on top of the world she's gonna get her
girlfriend like she's finally in her
first relationship and she's living her
truth she's part of something where
people support her so now she's starting
to make power place where maybe she
shouldn't be very Cheryl is that right
now I was loving all the musical moments
that we had last year especially the
musical episode Vanessa I knew that you
could sing you had originally auditioned
to play Josie we've heard Cheryl seemed
so much but Lily I gave you shoutouts
especially during all of our Sweetwater
Secrets episodes your voice is
sensational girl you can we be expecting
to see in these clubs would be a regular
thing like per season yeah I believe so
I think we are Berto just was so happy
with the way it turned out and there's
no way we won't do another one so Kevin
is just a musical but you can sing yeah
a lot I'm more of a rapper right but
your voice Heights yeah Cole will you
ever forsake in any of the music
I mean if it makes sense for Jughead oh
I like that I don't I didn't really ever
have a hard stance against it I just
assumed ease he didn't woman I didn't
want to drop an album for Disney when I
was a kid so yeah I didn't want to sing
there was a soft side well I mean for me
you know if if Jughead getting on stage
in front of a crowd feels like it's in
line with his character than then
totally fine okay
but he's fundamentally an antisocial kid
so it doesn't really seem like something
you would do
we'll see how many achieved
cheeseburgers but he can bread one with
yeah exactly
sometimes that's good lastly
congratulations you guys you're filling
up hull H tomorrow which is such a huge
accomplishment going into your third
season what do you want to say to all
the Riverdale fans who are watching live
right now in ETS YouTube channel and
just adore you all we like button and
subscribe keep on clicking hey keep on
clicking the button though yeah refresh
comments on the YouTube section right
now I adore you all so much and I really
hope to have you guys come back to
Sweetwater secrets because it's coming
back PT's youtube channel we always had
a lot of fun thank you all so much
[Music]